and welcome to everybody watching I'm
Jason gots with big thing and this
hangout is brought to you by big think
mentor our lifelong learning platform on
YouTube for personal and professional
growth I'm here with Ellen Galinsky
president of the families and Work
Institute and author of mind in the
making she's here to talk about the
seven essential life skills that are the
subject of her book and her workshop for
a big think mentor welcome Ellen thank
you for being with us thank you so much
Jason it's a real pleasure and I'd also
like to welcome three members of our big
think mentor community Christian Creek
oh and please correct me if I say your
neighborhood Nicholas
Oh actually Nicholas and whorin couldn't
be with us and Patrick Johnson welcomed
us thank you very much okay so I'd like
to start us off with a question for
Ellen and so there was a big article
this week in New York magazine which I'm
sure you saw on the negative power of
praise and it's one of many such
articles I've seen recently American
parents tend to focus on boosting kids
self-esteem and maybe Western parents
generally but the research of
psychologists Carol Dweck and others
suggest strongly that overpraise can
actually demotivate kids making them
reluctant to work at things that don't
come so easily to them so they give up
more easily how seriously should parents
teachers and even employers take this
message or these findings should we be
going back to the days when teachers
followed the maxim no smiling before
Christmas is you know is that is that
you know is it that serious and that
substantial as Carol Dweck says we have
been through the self-esteem movement
and she did a survey and found that the
large majority of parents believed that
the way that you boost kids self-esteem
is by praising them but it's not that
it's praise per se that's bad it's the
kind of praise that that really matters
most parents and most of us play praise
personality we praise character we say
you're really smarter you're a good
artist or and we don't praise the things
that motivate us to try harder to try
that that next challenge to take on a
challenge in in the mind of the making
view that that this is one of the
important life skills if we praise both
adults and children's effort you tried
really hard or you did this particular
use this particular strategy that is we
praise strategies then then kids then
adults will will work hard will stay
motivated and there's also research that
says that that the that the praise
whether you give very specific and
concrete praise or larger global praise
also matters that is if you're trying
something that's a real challenge then
talking about very specific first steps
that an adult might take tends to be
more motivating not I'm going to lose
weight but I'm gonna lose five pounds so
that also matters in terms of how we
talk to people and how we talk to
ourselves great and now I'd like to open
the floor to Christian and Patrick and
and we'll just go round robin christian
if you could ask one question and then
patrick and then we can go back to
christian and patrick and do two
questions each that way and great thanks
Jason I want to thank big think and and
Alan this is a great opportunity it's
very exciting that the opportunity to
speak directly with you and hear your
insights the first question I had Alan
was in school number three communicating
employers were reporting that
communication is a critical skill that
the younger workforce is lacking is
there a particular cost that you see for
why that's the case
you know workforce we asked an
open-ended question of a nationally
representative sample of employers in
the research that the families and Work
Institute does and way by and large they
say
that young people new entrance to the
workforce are not very good at both
whirl and written communication and I
think that it's because we don't teach
people to communicate in a sense you can
easily blank brain you know the the
Twitter world and the fact that we're
not really talking face to face for this
and and I'm sure that that has a part in
in how we communicate but we need to
teach people what I would think of as
the elevator speech that is think about
if you have a limited amount of time to
communicate one what do you really want
to say and then to and this would
involve this skill perspective-taking
how do you say it in a way that it can
be heard and that how do you say it in a
way that it can be heard we're not
teaching children were not teaching
adults how to do that my daughter got a
home master's in strategic
communications she spent you know two
and a half years at Columbia because she
runs a non-profit philanthropy that
funds social entrepreneurs and she finds
that the entrepreneurs that they fund
they started Teach for America City Year
etc she finds that the entrepreneurs who
succeed are the ones who are good
communicators and although they may have
a big bold idea to as social
entrepreneurs that can solve a really
tough problem if they don't know how to
communicate it well then they don't
necessarily succeed so she felt that in
her job is running this organization
called echoing green that if she could
help their grantees learn to communicate
better they would be able to achieve
their goals in much better ways gotcha
Thank You Patrick my first question was
on perspective taking mm-hmm and it was
about how we live in such a competitive
world
how does empathy or emotional
intelligence lighten competition well
it's interesting that's a great question
because in some ways we we live in a
very competitive
world and yet in the business world it
the the end of the era of the individual
hero I think is gone that is we can't
just depend on the Jonas salt to come up
with a polio vaccine it's going to take
a team and the smart employers I think
are building in team competencies not
just individual competencies where the
chemist and the physicist or or the
biologists if you're talking about
prevention of disease have to figure out
how to work together and so I think that
teaching the skill of perspective-taking
is critically important now it's
different than empathy it involves
empathy which is I feel what you feel
it's emotional intelligence is in a
sense a good concept because it involves
intelligence it's social emotional and
cognitive competencies and it helps you
understand the perspectives of others
and I can give an example I always think
of Admiral Michael Mullen who was the
chair of the Joint Chiefs of Staff and
when he and he was quite successful in
his job I think at least I feel he was
when he talks about what helped him go
into a into a country like Afghanistan
or Iraq or Iran he didn't do the usual
here's the history here's the geography
here are the key facts that you need to
know what he tried to understand is how
people who grew up in that culture would
think and that really helped him succeed
or you think of medical school there is
read the cost I read in the New York
Times today that the cost of health care
is going up and it keeps going up one of
the ways to control the cost of health
care is to improve patient doctor
communication that involves perspective
taking so medical schools are
increasingly asking future candidates
they're rating future candidates on
whether or not they can listen to the
patient understand the patient's own
view of his or her symptoms and then
communicate back so that there's a back
and forth communication and that's they
found that is one
way that they can really control costs
to reduce our you know to reduce the the
price of health care as it escalates in
this country so I think that the notion
of the competitive world is an
industrial era yes of course we're very
competitive yes of course I want my
organization to to win to succeed and
I'm sure all of us want to on an
individual level but we can do that best
by working with other people
not by you know putting them down and
pushing them off to the side of the road
thank you back to Christian well thank
you and these skills that seem so
fundamental right those baseline
fundamentals that they're it's ironic
that we're forgetting about them it's
not like this is not like new stuff at
all it's your point as where
virtualization is you know has happened
that you you know I'm in the technology
world it's so easy to think well
technology is the solution but without
the people and without the
communications that you speak to
technology is is worthless things better
in fact you know I deal obviously in the
marketplace with a lot of things I was
doing it yesterday and just counting on
computer screens to have all the right
information doesn't have the interaction
happening you don't get the social
aspect to it you don't get people to
help because well the computer screen
just says this so therefore I'm on to
the next customer oh you're missing the
fundamentals exactly I mean it does seem
that these skills are obvious and yet I
spent I was went into what became mine
to the making I didn't start out to
write a book I didn't start out to do
something called mind in the making I
started out with a real question which
is what do we do to children to turn off
the fire in their eyes all children are
born engaged in learning it's a survival
skill our brains are of all other beings
in the world
our brains are less developed at Birth
than any other species so we have to we
depend on the environment to write the
script for our genetic codes in a sense
if you want to use a technology analogy
so so much of hooey
and what we are comes from the
experiences we have after we were born
in fact they're calling the first three
months of life the fourth trimester
these days because so much is happening
during that time I could see across
disciplines that there are these skills
that that are emerging and yet most
schools most classrooms most parents
don't promote these skills and so it's
it's like hidden in plain sight it's
obvious but we're not paying attention
to it in a fundamental way and but when
you know it when you think about it then
it becomes obvious so the way that I
came up with seven and seven seems like
oh yeah good publishing number did you
just come up with seven because the
publisher said that would be a good
number hm no I mean and what I really
did was to take what I was seeing in the
research from neuroscience from
cognitive science from developmental
psychology etc and look at where there
were longitudinal studies what had
happened in that child's life to help
that child thrive now and in the future
and that's how the seven skills actually
emerged in a sense the seventh skill is
kind of cumulative which is
self-directed engaged learning it kind
of pulls them all together and focus the
self-control the first skill is is a
baseline in a sense because if you can't
pay attention you can't really learn the
other skills if you don't have the
self-control to not go on automatic then
you can't really learn to listen to what
someone else says for example with
perspective-taking
but you know the response to mine in the
making has been so much more than I ever
expected because these are obvious but
they're hidden in plain sight but
they're so simple to do something about
and we can teach these to adults we can
teach them to children we can promote
them in ourselves and it can make a big
difference in our lives if I can
interject before we take it over to
Patrick again you know one of the things
Ellen that I like most about what you're
saying in the book and in the mentor
workshop is that the seven essential
life skills basically you know which are
the skills that we need
be fully functional successful human
beings basically come down to learning
as a life like a lifelong orientation
toward learning they enable us to learn
they they you know they make us
effective learners and and it sort of
represents human beings as learning
beings throughout the lifespan which is
something that I mean on there are you
know two things one is we tend to think
of learning as something that stops when
you graduate from graduate school I mean
not not you know in some ways no but in
some ways yes like I'm done my learning
and now I'm doing my life you know and
and and and so the idea of that that
you're learning throughout your life is
not something that people necessarily
actively engage in you know past school
and then you know secondly we always
have this back-and-forth where on the
one hand we understand that it's good
for children to be curious and that we
want them to be active learners you know
in education and design and curriculum
and so forth and on the other hand we
have these exigencies of skills and so
forth that we feel we have to teach
children concrete things so that they
can remain competitive and so forth and
so on
that often you know create curriculums
and school systems that do the exact
opposite that as you say put out the
fire and yeah so I mean you know I
wonder kind of what it would take for
the orientation of whole educational
systems to shift in in such a way that
we are focusing on these kind of meta
skills that make for better learners you
know not only in sort of progressive
schools but also you know everywhere
more than we are on concrete right no
that is such a great question I just
love that so much because and all of
these are great questions
and the reason that I love it so much is
that it's it's like the notion of
competitiveness me against you always
and none of us are going to you know do
anything that matters without the help
of other people in one way or another
whether it's reading a book or actually
working with people who are as far our
sponsors or mentors or so forth the
notion of
is a very industrial era notion now I
think of the movie Waiting for Superman
and there's an image in it or I want
will where I went to myself and I
watched it that is exactly the way we
think about learning this was a school
presumably about education that were
waiting for Superman
and yet the image was of a kid whose
head was cut off and numbers and letters
and shapes and stuff report in so we
have this table Raza this kind of empty
vessel will pour in the knowledge notion
when everything we know about brain
science says that we are active learners
yesterday I met with an entrepreneur who
whose company has made a lot of money
and they want to figure out how to
improve the educational system because
they're not happy with the new entrants
to the workforce and he's trying to
learn about education he's going around
the country and figuring out what works
and what doesn't work and he was really
discouraged because he's thought that
most innovation in education depended on
the one charismatic leader and yes it
does if we keep the old model going but
if everyone becomes a learner then in
and and if we're always trying to
improve things then we can keep
improving education to better fit what
we know from science and to better fit
what we need in the 21st century I don't
think that I would have seen the skills
honestly if so much of my work at the
families and Work Institute weren't with
the adult workforce and workplace I mean
I just have you know hear that
discussion all day long and you know in
the research that we do and in the
employers we work with so one thing that
has really gratified me and I'm sorry
this is a long answer but you've gotten
my my soapbox here is that we are out
now in about 14 communities where we
have taken the book and turned it into
training modules and and they're and
they're really actually we call them
learning modules not training modules
cause training is the old view of what
learning is but learning modules and
I've seen that fire come back in adult
size the teachers the principal's the
superintendent's the pediatricians the
social workers the language therapists
they get excited about learning by going
out because we share the actual research
you see Carol Dweck you know in live
Living Color doing her studies and
talking about what she found in our
modules you have really experiences in
learning yourself and we've seen that
have the ability to begin to transform
the educational system in ways that
honest-to-god I didn't think we're
possible but when you get adults excited
when they own the innovation that they
need when they base it on science I
think we can begin to reinvent the way
we think of think the way we think about
teaching and learning good and Patrick
I'm sorry I jumped in there but I
definitely you know was sparked by what
was going on in the conversation so go
ahead and please ask your next question
definitely yeah the way we learn and how
it how we think about it like socially
cognitively emotionally and how we can
relate that to school and within like
this classroom lectures and independent
reading independent learning and also
like clinical rotation or something
where you get hands-on experience so I
can see I can see your point there I'll
go to my next question here it's on
critical thinking and it was on how can
we generate how can critical thinking
generate positive or negative actions
and reactions
that's a great question a complicated
question
I feel that the world is so a washed
with information that is very hard to
know what's what's real I mean you can
watch the same news story on two
different channels and to get to totally
the same event
presumably and you get two totally
different interpretations depending on
the point of view of the commentator and
the channels that you've happened to
turn into a radio the same or newspapers
the same anyway that we get information
about the world that we don't directly
experience and how do we know how to
make decisions because our decisions who
we vote for
or how we live our lives depend on how
we see this experience that where we
don't have direct knowledge of it I mean
we can't you know maybe in in a very
pre-industrial agricultural world we
could have direct experience with
everything that we needed to know about
we can't do that anymore we have we have
to outsource our knowledge so I think
that by and large critical thinking is
an important skill because it's the
ongoing surgeons that word ongoings is
critical here the ongoing search for
ballot and reliable information so you
have to understand when information is
not accurate when it's what researchers
would call confounded because you can't
say that a always leads to B you you
know it's just it's more complicated
than that and other things get in there
and so I think teaching children not
just let's say science but how
scientific thinking takes place has been
found to improve them in all sorts of
other areas I'm thinking of the research
that's going on at Carnegie Mellon my
David Clark for example he found that
kids in the seventh grade eighth grade
etc were never thought how to conduct a
good experiment they were always told
here's the experiment and here's what it
learned but not how do you know whether
it's a really good experiment and when
he actually taught kids how what a good
experiment was and how would how would
you know what you've learned from this
experiment it made a big difference in
in the kids lives and performance so I
think by enlarge it's mostly a positive
result but of course you know we get
lots of knowledge that it's hard to
figure out whether it is reliable and
accurate and I guess that's the bad side
of it how do we know with you know the
thousands of Twitter fees we get every
day what's real and what's not real
definitely and I think that's what kind
of Drew me to big think is uh we're not
independently learn for myself I go I'll
use like databases through school and
like go after research-based articles
and there's a bunch information
you know bunch of different articles
once your friend place it in to draw
this information from and I'm not saying
it was a bad way to do it but I like how
big thing takes it and do a different
perspective and like kind of breaks it
down for you and helps you understand it
in in terms of your own life and what
you're doing so thank you for that well
I'm a total fan of big think when when
we decided to work together I was like I
couldn't have been more wildly excited
as Jason knows because he got my
euphoric email us back to him when we
started this conversation I think that
it brings people together in in a way
that we can now with technology I mean
we can have this conversation and you
know you can push back at me and I love
that and I can hopefully push back at
you and I love that too we can have we
can do the big thinking that we need to
do to be able to live our lives in the
way that we want to yeah I mean we're
not to turn this into an extended
advertisement for big thing but but you
know having worked here for two years I
what I like best about it is the fact
that you know we can connect with people
like you Ellen and that now through you
know through through mentor and things
like this hang out you know we can
actually connect directly with our
audience in spite of the fact that what
we do kind of happens out there on the
big impersonal web and you know in the
past we've we've mainly been feeding you
know video out to the world it's it's
it's amazing now to be able to just sit
and interact in this way and really kick
the ideas around so I think we've we've
really come to the end of our half-hour
and so I want to say thank you to
everybody out there in the audience for
joining us today
and and thank you especially Ellen
Galinsky for being with us you've been
watching our big think mentor hangout
with Ellen Galinsky who's author of mind
in the making and you can visit
youtube.com slash user slash big think
mentor to view Ellen's video workshop
based on her book called the seven
essential life
skills and and thank you so much for
being with us also today Christian and
Patrick thank you it's great thank you
thank you as a pleasure to meet you
you too yeah